welcome to great big story YouTube
channel I'm Dave I'm Jillian let's watch
some stories this episode is all about
the arc
first up typewriter orchestra my name is
Alice Holman and I play tenor
smith-corona with the Boston typewriter
Orchestra the Boston Piper - orchestra
is an ensemble for typewriter invoice
some of us have musical backgrounds some
of us don't several of our members play
in bands currently I haven't touched
much of anything except for typewriters
since playing the trombone in high
school we play a wide variety of
typewriters from some small portable
models all the way up to some relatively
large death models a lot of what we do
in building up songs is really exploring
what different sounds we can get out of
the typewriter and how we can
incorporate them into a song for example
you have the the key you make sort of a
a basic clack sound but then you have
the the shift that moves a lot of
mechanics and make somewhat of a bass
sound then you also have the the roller
that gets a get sort of a mechanical
ratchet sound to it and then all of them
we can work with the carriage return for
like this you know the standard sweepy
sound to it as their name suggests the
Boston type of the orchestra is Boston
based but we've actually played all over
New England
most of the typewriters are 50 60 70
years old usually in our hands we see
two to three years of lifespan we feed
on them pretty hard
my fingers are when we started out in
2004 we were you're a bunch of guys
getting together and
banging on typewriters we get that we're
kind of weird it's a little bit of a
wacky idea but we've discovered that
this makes some legitimate music and you
know it can be a real serious endeavor
we have true songs that come together
and people seem to really enjoy them and
as long as we still are entertaining
people we're going to stay out there
typing here's the question what did your
favorite song look like well I don't
know but Melissa does and that's what
her art is all about
I started painting music just because I
would try to explain synesthesia so many
times it never quite made as much sense
to describe it verbally so I thought it
would be best just to put it on canvas
because I've always been an artist and
it made it much easier for people to be
able to understand it
[Music]
my name is Melissa McCracken and I am a
synesthetic artist synesthesia is a
neurological condition where your brain
is basically crosswire so certain
stimuli will come in and it will create
the wrong response in my brain so for me
that's listening to music and it's
translated into color in my head I'm
going to paint superstitions by Stevie
Wonder I love a song superstition just
because it's dynamic and funky and just
funnin expressive whenever I start a
piece actually listen to the song first
to even know what kind of colors I'd
like to use there are some songs that I
hate that I like the way that they look
a little bit like a lot of pop music it
can be pink and purple and you know just
all these fun bright colors but songs
about bag so one of the other I
appreciate it somehow you know you kind
of really have to be in the right vibe
to be able to paint if you're not in the
right vibe you're not going to make
anything good I think the prints on
Rasmussen's jazz music I love blues and
golds and whites and it just seemed very
pearly and iridescent a little bit when
I listened to Etta James at last the
thing that stuck out most to me was just
her voice the very beginning when she
goes to the last
and it's just a very bright and but also
warm sort of feeling very kind of
classic jazzy which jazz music generally
has a very gold and blue sort of look to
it music has always been a very big part
of my life my older brother is very
musical and when I think back of him
playing the guitar for me I think of the
colors of what those memories are I was
always a little disappointed because I
was never very musically inclined it was
really cool to have a way to bring music
into you know my life and a different
sort of way this next story is all about
fusing two different kinds of dance
we're going to hit the streets of
Chicago and see what that's all about
people say that like oh like a doing man
because let go can do ballet so this is
an alternative it has nothing to do with
it I will tell you every girl in this
studio is classically trained everyone
does ballet and everything else oh well
my name is the poor Wolfson and I'm a
hip slate dancer
Hitler is a mixture of hip-hop and
ballet but really anything that we can
try to put on point that had with the
groovy feeling to it
my name is Omaha and I'm the founder of
hit Lake and the founder and director of
the Chicago multicultural Dance Center I
think some people get mad where we play
fierce - in here playing it's not
traditional classical ballet we're
ruining ballets well no it's not valid
hit play it's how we empower our kids is
how we empower the world Kipling is so
freeing and so open there's a different
culture here
little Hitler movements are the hips
let's start the twist in and out the
moonwalk civilian and resistance just
have a certain posture when you're doing
that usually you're appalled like
straight pigeon posture everything
points you would design for ballet pitch
way is different a hip like you can
break that you can just will we move
your torso more and you can bounce with
it you know you can have fun with it I
grew up thinking that I couldn't do
Valerie because of the color of my skin
at my old studio because I was
african-american I was often overlooked
until I came to see me diffused when I
will be run that there was something off
I'm grateful to mr. Homer because he
showed me that I can do anything I love
dancing and hip flick it gives you a
sort of a confidence and just of freedom
like just to be yourself
this is the dance on or that does not
discriminate
we have rhythm when you can groove on
point you got it now we're just figured
guys know why to learn about the art of
hula and we'll see what it takes to be a
champion hula is the language of the
heart and therefore the heartbeat of the
Hawaiian people and we tell our dancers
everything is death your hair your
toenail your eyelashes it needs to be
done Nalu olio hie hey you know ah
[Music]
[Applause]
within three days the competition
tickets are sold out those tickets are
like gold they only bring the best of
the best and so we're very honored to be
able to participate the most prestigious
part of Merrie Monarch is the miserable
hula competition which is the women's
solo competition both allows are allowed
to choose their very best answer
our contestant this year came iike all a
new car new canoe many is a professional
hula dancer and we chose her for many we
wanted to destroy not just a dancer but
as a person what you all did it
you are plenty of fish and you had no
kebab in the old shop Johanna one of my
favorite parts about Mary mark week is
that we goes to gaol to due respect to
pellet with the fire goddess I got a
subscription and it really puts into
perspective where you are in this world
and in this pool of journey
[Music]
I've wanted to be in Mary Marsh since I
was a little kid there was a lot of
times where I thought I would never it
would never happen for me but pretty
much most of my school attorney has been
working towards this moment which is
tomorrow professionally I've been doing
it since 2009 there's a difference
between dancing hula and Hollow and then
singular professionally dancing for the
truth is like American Chinese and not
the authentic consistent ideas food and
hotel here's what you beautiful men and
women brightly colored hair pieces and
lathe which are all plastic but you
won't even skill you want you to love
that you would as a merry monarch
festival for Mary mater who practiced
every day for I would say three to four
months their intent can we try to and
one more time wife you guys waiting
invitation you need one invitation come
on you guys
get your head game on the biggest
misconception of all who knows that it's
easy all hula dancers and yukl remnants
have bad knees all of them so when you
see a beautiful hula dancer it's gliding
across the stage she curvy
she's hurting really bad because nobody
walks around with bent knees you know
six inches off the ground blisters you
get blisters on your feet every single
part of your body needs to work you
should be gasping for air but you can
you need to look exactly the same as
when you first started if you can bend
your knees and for your head and Paget's
upper body carries that's really afraid
but make it effortless that's actually
ladies and gentlemen welcome this allahu
la competición kingly put your money
pause if I gave the performance of a
lifetime if I gave everything I had to
that one performance those 14 minutes up
there just me I've already won
Oh
it's just successful for all of these
people that came before you for all the
knowledge that you have and it's your
responsibility to share that if you're
responsible it needs to go fetch me but
it would be so nice to hear my name
being called and now ladies and
gentleman mr. Lowell hula for 2016
Kaley
[Applause]
you know I don't dance to logic to be
able I would because because I love it
and I kind of cling to you why I do I
think it's something you just written
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks for stopping by to watch these
four great day stories with us
click the horse to subscribe and leave a
message below we'll see you next okay
[Music]